this is a production of Cornell
University
okay good morning I'm Greg Peck and I
love monologist meaning I work with food
crops and particularly with orchard
systems and very specifically with apple
orchard systems and so we've been
thinking a lot about soil health for
orchard systems for a long time many
decades and it's been a big part of my
graduate research and in my professional
research since then but some of the
things that are quite different about
apple orchards and vegetable systems or
about row crop systems and agronomic
crops is that we only get into the soil
about once every 20 to 30 years to do
tillage practices that's our opportunity
to cover crops we do pre planned cover
cropping we might add some compost we
adjust pH then we plant the trees and
then the perennial system so those trees
are there for a very long time for
decades so then the question becomes
well from a soil health perspective what
can we do to increase the soil health of
the system orchards have very different
root structures than annual systems but
also we've seen a change in our orchard
systems over the past thirty years and
so that top picture shows what a
traditional orchard looked like thirty
years ago
widely spaced trees on a 25 by 25 foot
grid now we plant trees three feet apart
some girls are now even planting trees a
foot and a half apart and twelve feet
between rows so very intensive systems
they require a lot more precision in
terms of our nutrient use in terms of
our water use and potentially we have an
opportunity here to do things to the
soil to make those trees more productive
so the bottom picture there is showing
myself and former graduate student who's
no professor out at Oregon State with
some dwarfing rootstocks so we're using
these new genotypes that produce very
small trees and with that very small
root systems so one of the ways that
we've been looking at to increase soil
health and orchard systems is through
the use of mulch
and so whereas we can't use cover crops
since her defrosting a compost on an
annual basis we can mulch on and what
we're finding is is that while sometimes
tree growth and yield is is not always
improved although I'd have to say look
back at three of the last studies that
we did and we always found a increase in
tree growth particularly for our young
plantings by using mulch and where I
think we're seeing that more
particularly in years like two years ago
and again this year when we have it a
very dry June after planting but we're
seeing all these other benefits for soil
health that have been talked about
already this morning and many of you are
familiar with increasing soil organic
matter increasing the water holding
capacity increasing biological activity
making nutrients and minerals available
for the plants we see some suppressive
effects for diseases erosion control on
hillsides which is really important for
our Hudson River Valley growers that
grow on more slopes and on the picture
here this is actually a organically
managed orchard and we're finding that
we are able to control weeds effectively
with mulch with an overlay of a second
practice so if we do mulch with an
herbicide we with an organic herbicide
we can have a weed free strip that is
very similar to what the conventional
growers are getting with with Street
herbicide so this has always been the
barrier for organic it's always we
control true in in any cropping system
and it's true in an orchard systems so
it's really exciting we're finding tons
of benefits reduced leaching of
nutrients and pesticides into the soil
so mulch is really where it's at
other positive effects what this chart
is showing you is that under mulch which
for the bars the four bars on the left
side are the mulch treatments and the
bars on the right hand side are
different no mulch treatments with
without compost with without calcium
nitrate that mulching is increasing
mycorrhizae in the soil so these are
microorganisms that are helping getting
water and phosphorus into the plant and
we're finding great benefits from that
so things that growers me
realize are happening or happening below
the ground so with the soil health
project we really want our metrics we
want ways of trying to understand how do
we measure soil health for orchard
systems we may not always be able to
show it in short-term dollars and cents
but we can show it in long-term benefits
the soil long term benefits to the
environment and I think that's really
important for us as we think about soil
health is that we expand the crops that
we're looking at we're looking at
agronomic crops we're looking at
vegetable system and that we're also
looking at cranial fruit systems this is
another picture of just a trial looking
at integrating practices compost and
nutrients and other ways of thinking
about this creatively Ann Arbor is are
very interested in this I was just
invited on Thursday to talk to soil
health - about finding 50 commercial
apple growers along Lake Ontario so they
are asking these questions and these are
not organic just organic growers these
are our largest conventional mainstream
growers in the state are very interested
so thanks
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu